[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
Parlement Hebdo l'émission qui vous fait
revivre les moments forts de l'actualité
à l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat avec
Quentin Calmet bonjour Quentin nous
accueillons cette semaine Éliane
assassin bonjour c'est la triste de
Seine-Saint-Denis et présidente du
groupe communiste au Sénat oui bonjour
vous êtes rentrés dans la lumière avec
la commission d'enquête sur les cabinets
de conseils la faire McKinsey vous étiez
rapporteur de cette commission et on a
vu que cette commission a intéressé de
nombreux Français on va y revenir dans
cette émission
et l'image de la semaine c'est bien sûr
et Elizabeth borne à l'Assemblée
nationale la première ministre a choisi
de recourir à l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution pour éviter le rejet du
budget
la proposition de loi encadrant le
recours au cabinet de conseil privé
adopté au Sénat un vote à la quasi
unanimité sur votre texte il y a
assassin on en parle bien sûr
les sénateurs qui ont en revanche rejeté
l'inscription du droit l'IVG dans la
Constitution deux autres propositions de
loi arriveront à l'Assemblée en novembre
mais donc on passe au premier thème de
cette émission avec ce recours au 49-3
sur la première partie du budget il
faisait peu de mystère que l'exécutif y
aurait recours faute d'une majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale mais
donc Isabelle l'a annoncé à la tribune
c'était mercredi après-midi deux motions
de censure ont été déposés le récit de
Stéphanie de pierre
et alors qu'il reste presque 2000
amendements la première ministre monte à
la tribune de l'Assemblée sur le
fondement de l'article 49
de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement pour la première partie du
projet de loi de finance pour 2023 en
réaction les 150 députés de la nupesse
des postes immédiatement une motion de
censure pour tenter de faire tomber le
gouvernement nous avons la preuve une
nouvelle fois qu'ils ont choisi la
brutalité alors pourquoi choisi-t-il à
brutalité d'abord parce qu'ils sont
minoritaires dans cette hémicycle parce
que le vote de la représentation
nationale leur a déplu et nous ne
considérons que c'est une honte pour
notre démocratie de se comporter de
cette façon il y a une opposition qu'une
opposition forte c'est celle qui a été
envoyé par les Français nous demandons à
ce qu'elle se respectait les macronistes
renvoient la responsabilité du 49.3 aux
oppositions toutes les oppositions se
sont alliées pour nous dire qu'elles
allaient voter contre ce budget et le
49-3 c'est de leur responsabilité à elle
nous en gouvernement et majorité
responsable on souhaite pouvoir protéger
les Français de l'inflation on souhaite
pouvoir payer les Français au 1er
janvier prochain la France a besoin d'un
budget c'est chacun sa motion de censure
le lendemain le rassemblement national
en dépose une seconde signée par ses 89
députés le gouvernement de n'a pas pris
acte en fait des résultats des
législatives il croit toujours qu'il est
majoritaire qui peut faire passer ses
feuilles de route malgré le vote des
Français il ne fait pas de vrais
dialogue et surtout il ne fait pas de
compromis dans l'hémicycle c'est la
droite qui peut faire basculer la
majorité d'un côté ou de l'autre mais
pour les républicains pas question de
déposer ou de voter une motion de
censure
de rajouter du désordre au désordre
laissons cet assemblée travaillait sans
le soutien DLR l'émotion de censure
n'ont aucune chance d'être adopté le
gouvernement ne devrait pas être
renversé
il est assassiner les oppositions
fustigent cette décision de courir de
recourir à l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution criant au déni de
démocratie on le comprend mais d'un
autre côté il fallait bien passer le
budget la procédure et règlementée il y
a 70 jours pour faire passer le budget
quel autre choix le gouvernement
avait-il bah l'autre choix c'est tout
simplement
d'accepter le débat démocratique au sein
de au sein de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est quand même assez étonnant que
quelques jours après le début de
l'examen du PLF du projet boite finance
donc le gouvernement dégaine l’arme
fatale qui est le
49-3 ce n'est pas une surprise
ne va pas se mentir ce n'est pas une
surprise dans le même temps le
gouvernement donc ce n'est une surprise
pour personne ni pour le gouvernement ni
pour nous-mêmes donc moi ce que je
regrette c'est que le gouvernement et
Madame borne en particulier n'est pas
appréhendé ce sujet
elle a passé son temps à rencontrer les
groupes politiques du Sénat et de et de
l'Assemblée nationale et au bout du bout
elle nous a vu elle nous a écouté mais
elle ne nous a pas entendu mais parce
que elle est dans un couloir dans son
couloir elle est en mission c'est une
mission qui lui a été confiée par le
Président de la République et elle ne
sort pas de son couloir le fait que ce
n'est quand même pas surprenant qu'une
opposition face de l'opposition qu'une
opposition phase de l'opposition mais
phase est propositions également parce
qu'on ne reste pas dans des postures
simplement d'opposition on fait un
certain nombre de propositions
parce qu'ils savent qu'il y a un certain
nombre de sujets qui font écho dans la
tête des gens l'attaque sur les supers
profits par exemple ils ont peur de la
concret le débat il craignent le débat
démocratique et que de nouvelles
propositions émergent un peu dans le
débat public c'est pareil sur je parlais
de l'attaque sur les super profits je
pourrais parler des collectivités et des
problèmes de dépenses d'énergie etc etc
c'est des sujets forts qui préoccupent
les gens et donc ils ne veulent pas
parler il est nécessaire de la nuque ont
immédiatement quitté l'hémicycle lorsque
le 49-3 a été annoncé la députée
Mathilde de panneaux pour le groupe la
France insoumise a annoncé que la nuque
allait déposer une motion de censure
elle fasse un macronisme devenu un
autoritarisme c'est une c'est un outil
constitutionnelle le 49-3 vous le
reconnaissez pas vous aurez repris le
mode autoritarisme il est pas nouveau ce
mot quand même d'autoritarisme je
rappelle quand même que dans le premier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron à
plusieurs reprises nous avons soulevé
effectivement ce comportement
autoritaire et quelque part un peu se
mépris aussi à l'égard du Parlement en
fait c'est pas nouveau et après que
l'opposition de gauche en particulier
dépose une motion de censure c'est
normal c'est et inscrit dans les textes
et on use nous aussi des possibilités
que la Constitution nous offre donc
c'est tout à fait normal c'est
effectivement passé rapidement derrière
les oppositions ce sont mobilisées pour
déposer des d'émotions de censure mais
elles seront 5 en clair il n'y a pas de
motion commune pour renverser le
gouvernement ça veut dire que les
oppositions ne sont pas non plus prêtes
à affronter une dissolution non mais je
pense que c'est aussi
un moyen pour pouvoir dire ce qu'on a
pas pu dire à cause du 49-3 donc c'est
émotion de vos va être utile aux forces
qu'il est c'est du temps et du temps de
débat pour voilà poursuivre et puis on
est au milieu du gué il y a le PLF et le
PLFSS vont arriver après au Sénat alors
ils vont arriver au Sénat notamment le
PLF le projet de loi de finance donc le
budget de l'État vous attendez un débat
riche au Sénat où on pourrait aussi
avoir des surprises comme par exemple la
taxation sur les super conflits vous le
croyez je pense que il y a une
proposition de de loi constitutionnelle
qui circule pour l'organisation d'un
d'un RIP sur la taxation des super
profits je pense qu'il y a il peut y
avoir des avancées
portent aussi cette idée ici vous allez
faire au Sénat le débat qui n'a pas eu
lieu l'assemblée
de l'Assemblée nationale qui n'ont pas
pu débattre ils sont comprennent bien
est-ce que ça a une chance d'aller au
bout ou est-ce qu'à la fin le 49-3 est
le dernier mot de la nationale on parle
encore effacer le travail du Sénat non
parce que d'une part il n'y a pas de
49-3 au Sénat et d'autre part
la représentation sénatoriale n'est pas
du tout la même can Assemblée nationale
donc il y a aussi une volonté des
groupes politiques à la au Sénat de
débattre de ces deux textes fondamentaux
quand même pour pour nos concitoyens et
nos concitoyens que sont le budget et
puis celui-là la sécurité sociale donc
je crois qu'il va qui on aime le débat
on aime le débat aussi on aime la
contradiction on aime les oppositions on
se respecte et moi je vous le dis pour
ce qui concerne mon groupe nous allons
déposer beaucoup d'abonnement qui ne
sont pas simplement dans des postures
d'opposition mais qui vont faire un
certain nombre de propositions et je
pense que le débat pourra être riche en
attendant ce débat au Sénat à
l'Assemblée c'est donc deux usages de
49-3 qui ont été faits par Elizabeth
donc une fois vous l'avez dit sur le
projet de loi de finance et ce jeudi à
vers 19h40 sur le budget de la Sécu
c'est le début d'une longue pelleté de
utiliser
autant sur les lois finance les lois de
finances le gouvernement peut dégainer
de 49-3 quand il le souhaite mais après
non non et après il ne peut le faire que
sur un texte donc on peut on peut on
peut s'attendre pour 2023 puisque 2022
va se clore on peut s'attendre que pour
2023 le gouvernement envisage l'idée de
dégainer le 49-3 sur le projet de loi
relatif en retraite et on n'y est pas
pour l'instant on va parler avec ce qui
vous concerne directement à lire la
Sassy dans un rapport rendu à la mi-mars
vous avez dénoncé l'opacité d'un recours
à ces entreprises privées devenu un
réflexe pour l'administration et le
gouvernement les cabinets de conseil
dernière étape de votre travail vous
avez transformé vos recommandations en
proposition de loi adopter à la quasi
unanimité récit de Céline Siksou
au terme d'une longue nuit mardi soir le
Sénat adopté à la quasi unanimité la
proposition de loi sur les cabinets de
conseils pour le projet de la
proposition de loi 331 contre 0 la
proposition est donc adoptée
avec ce texte le Sénat veut inscrire
dans le marbre les travaux de la
commission d'enquête il s'agit non pas
d'interdire le recours au cabinet de
conseil mais de mieux les encadrer car
selon l'une des auteurs du rapport il y
en assassy depuis que le Sénat rendu ses
conclusions le gouvernement reste opaque
sur les prestations de ses cabinets si
notre commission d'enquête a été un
exercice de transparence démocratique on
constate un retour à l'opacité depuis
au-delà de l'exercice de communication
le jaune que le gouvernement a publié la
semaine dernière et lacunaire et je dois
dire très décevant car le gouvernement
se refuse à publier la liste de ses
prestations de conseils alors qu'il
s'agit d'une information essentielle que
nos concitoyens sont en droit de
connaître le texte définit les
prestations des cabinets de conseils et
fixent les règles déontologiques en cas
de non-respects de ses règles il prévoit
une sanction pouvant aller jusqu'à 2% du
chiffre d'affaires annuel mondial enfin
il prévoit d'obliger les consultants à
faire une déclaration d'intérêt auprès
de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique en
séance le gouvernement a proposé de
l'appliquer ce dispositif qu'aux
dirigeants des cabinets mais les
sénateurs ont rejeté cet amendement des
consultants on fait part de leurs
inquiétudes dans la presse les
déclarations d'intérêts seraient trop
lourdes et les forces à s'éloigner du
secteur public qu'il sera sûr il sera
sûr en tant que parlementaire nous
remplissons des déclarations d'intérêt
depuis 2013 la première prend un peu de
temps il suffit de l'actualiser je pense
que des bacs plus 10 il parviendront
sans grande difficulté
Stanislas Guérini le ministre de la
Fonction publique s'est engagé à
inscrire le texte à l'agenda de
l'Assemblée nationale alors
suivi les travaux de la commission
l'affaire McKinsey maintenant vous voyez
le vote de votre texte à la case
unanimité en 331 pour zéro contre sur
344 votants vous vous saluez c'est
uneanimité du Sénat oui oui bien sûr je
salue je suis très heureuse de ce de ce
vote
en fait n'est que le résultat d'un long
processus où j'ai tenu comme rapporteur
sur sur ce texte de rassembler de
travailler tout ce qui converge du point
de vue des attentes des formations enfin
des groupes politiques etc donc je
voulais vraiment que ce soit un texte
transpartisant et je dois dire que j'ai
bien été accompagné par le président
Bazin en la en la matière qui est l'air
donc qui n'est pas voilà du comité
déontologie ici
alors ce n'est pas la commission
d'enquête McKinsey c'est une française
comme ça
donc il y a eu un long processus de
travail transpartisant sérieux rigoureux
etc et et finalement le vote et la
résultante de tout ce de tout ce
processus donc voilà moi je je m'en
félicite c'était
c'était pas évident au départ que le
groupe communiste qu'une commission
d'enquête demandée par le groupe
communiste soit validé par tout le monde
et que le fait que ce soit la présidente
du groupe qui qui en soit la rapporteur
aussi soit effectivement un élément de
stabilité je vais dire donc vous avez
constaté un consensus relativement
important sur ce sujet des cabinets de
conseils qui posent quand même problème
puisque les sommes sont pas abramineuses
le recours coûterait au moins un
milliard d'euros à l'État sur une année
sur une année sur une année sur une
année est-ce qu'il y aurait un domaine
parce que c'est quand même surprenant ce
chiffre un domaine que vous pourriez
nous citer dans lequel l'État pourrait
se passer de ces cabinets de conseils il
y a plusieurs domaines moi ce que je
regrette c'est que nous avons une
administration d'État qui est assez
comment dire voilà qui connaît son
métier qui a le sens de du service
public de l'intérêt général etc et que
ces gens là fonctionnaires là on les
laisse de côté et on confie des missions
à des cabinets alors que c'est
fonctionnaires sont en capacité donc ce
serait une source d'économie pour l'État
bah oui bien de permettre à ces
fonctionnaires d'assurer et
de confiance parce qu'il y a aussi quand
on confie des missions à des cabinets
notamment des cabinets internationaux
voilà il y a quand même des données qui
peuvent voilà des données sensibles qui
peuvent leur être confiés moi je préfère
confier des missions comme celle-ci à
nos fonctionnaires plutôt qu'à des
cabinets cabinets privés que dire de la
tissu de Stanislas Guérini dans cette
affaire parce qu'on avait vu lorsque
vous aviez rendu votre rapport en mars
on a vu l'exécutif plutôt tenter de
minimiser vos conclusions là le ministre
semble aller dans votre sens il dit
qu'il est volontaire pour aller dans le
sens de vos de vos mesures comment
est-ce que vous voyez l'attitude de
l'exécutif il y a eu un retournement de
situation un changement de ton non non
depuis le début de notre commission
d'enquête il y a eu plusieurs
interventions de objectifs dans nos
travaux mais tous placés sous le signe
de la défensive on a eu la circulaire du
Premier ministre Jean Castex le jour où
nous avons auditionné non madame Amélie
demouche il y a eu la conférence de
presse lunaire de Madame de Montchalin
et de Monsieur
dupes
le syndicat des cabinets conseils qui
ont qui ont pondu entre guillemets une
directive sur les règles déontologiques
qu'il se devait de respecter enfin bon
bref
[Musique]
souligner l'importance d'avoir un
document budgétaire sur le recours à ces
missions de cabinet
dont tax a été entendu mais vous avez vu
le jaune budgétaire qui nous a été
présenté il y a rien il y a rien dedans
c'est-à-dire que il mentionne simplement
la moitié des sommes que nous
mentionnons dans notre rapport il est
lacunaire question très concrète pour
finir sur ce thème est-ce que vous
pensez que votre proposition de loi sera
inscrite alors du jour à assemblée
bientôt ou alors à la Saint-Glinglin
c'est la question maintenant alors
d'abord il faut me connaître je suis
très tenace je ne sais pas si le
gouvernement le déposera j'ai des doutes
je ne sais pas si à l'instar du
président du Sénat la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale a comment dire
acceptera de le mettre dans une semaine
dédiée aux travaux ce qu'on appelle
l'initiative parlementaire ici moi je
vais créer les conditions en tout en
tous les cas pour que ce soit dans une
niche à l'Assemblée nationale
mais voilà c'est ça mais ce que je
souhaiterais c'est que cette dynamique
transpartisane qui a existé au Sénat
puisse exister encore à l'Assemblée
nationale et bien on verra ça dans les
prochains mois allez on passe au dernier
temps fort cette semaine la gauche
sénatoriale qui a proposé d'inscrire
l'accès à l'IVG dans la Constitution une
façon de protéger ce droit mais le texte
n'a pas été soutenu par la droite
sénatoriale écoutez tout d'abord Mélanie
Vogel à l'origine du texte et ensuite la
rapporteur LR Agnès canaille
souhaitons-nous montrer à toutes les
femmes du monde à toutes celles et ceux
qui se battent si nombreuses et si
nombreux contre le fascisme contre le
totalitarisme religieux celui des Molay
iraniens des évangélistes texan ou des
intégristes bien français à toutes
celles et ceux qui en Pologne en Hongrie
en Italie aux États-Unis en Iran au
Maroc à Malte dans le temps de pays se
battent pour avoir le droit d'être
considéré comme des êtres humains qui
disposent de leur corps et au fond de
leur destin et de leur vie que non tout
n'est pas perdu une procédure de
révision constitutionnelle à
l'initiative des parlementaires imposent
le recours au référendum conformément à
l'article 89 de la Constitution or il
existe un risque réel que cette
initiative se retourne contre les droits
qu'elle est censée protéger comme nous
ont alerté toutes les personnes
auditionnées y compris les auteurs
Hélène associe en quoi y a-t-il urgence
à inscrire ou non le droit à l'IVG dans
la Constitution est-ce qu'on n'est pas
en train d'importer un débat venu des
États-Unis non non je crois qu'il faut
balayer ces arguments qui viennent
notamment de
d'abord je voudrais dire quand on veut
pas on veut pas
puisqu'il y a quand même plusieurs
politiques qui ont déposé des
propositions de loi pour inscrire l'IVG
dans la Constitution y compris à
l'Assemblée nationale je crois savoir
que la présidente du groupe Renaissance
a elle aussi proposé une proposition de
loi mais ce n'est pas simplement ce qui
s'est passé aux États-Unis qui est
scandaleux je rappelle quand même que
des propositions de loi ça fait près de
plus de 10 ans que certaines d'entre
elles ont été posées sur les bureaux nos
assemblées il y en a eu une en 2012 je
crois la nôtre en 2018 donc bien avant
ce qui s'est passé donc on apporte rien
du tout les gens qui sont opposés à
l'IVG dans l'émission
on sent bien que au-delà Dieu de ce qui
s'est passé aux États-Unis c'est un
droit fragile c'est un droit fragile au
Parlement français vous le croyez et
notamment au Sénat ah oui
la preuve alors elle peut dire aussi que
c'est pas le la bonne idée de l'inscrire
ou que le texte est mal écrit comme Eddy
Philippe pense que c'est une bonne idée
que de d'inscrire ce droit dans la
Constitution parce que vous pensez de
l'argument d'Agnès canaillé qui de dire
si on ouvre une campagne référendaire ça
va aussi donner la parole aux Antilles
végés et ça peut aussi un danger dans le
pays
la démocratie ça a du sens quand même et
donc y compris sur des sujets qui
peuvent paraître sensibles moi je ne
pense pas qu'il soit sauf si parce que
je pense que dans notre pays il y a une
majorité de gens qui sont favorables à
protéger ce droit à la à l'IVG et de
l'inscrire dans la Constitution alors au
débat c'est quoi c'est quoi le problème
quel est le problème moi je vais vous
dire quel est le problème parce que
Monsieur le Ministre de la Justice a
fait un plaidoyer très intéressant voilà
et donc je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure
la présidente du groupe Renaissance a
déposé une proposition de loi donc il ne
fallait pas que elle soit adoptée ici
on a porté par les groupes de gauche et
quelques élus sont tristes et des
républicains mais plutôt donc c'est une
installation
alors il y a plusieurs propositions de
loi effectivement qui sont déposées y
compris de la part de la nupes à
l'Assemblée s'il y en a plusieurs et
qu'il ne reste qu'un à la fin et c'est
le texte d'Aurore berger est-ce que vous
si vous étiez député vous voteriez oui
le texte oui parce que des fois il faut
savoir dépasser
et oui un dernier mot est ce que vous
pensez que le droit à l'IVG est en
danger en France aujourd'hui pour les
femmes dans leur accès à ça
il l'est dans les déserts médicaux ça
c'est une réalité mais pas que dans les
dés parce que les déserts médicaux
s'entendre sur ce que veut dire des arts
médicaux en Seine-Saint-Denis c'est un
désert médical
ce n'est pas que le moindre donc il y a
des difficultés d'accès à ce droit
partout en France donc ça c'est une
réalité ce n'est pas la Constitution qui
va régler ce ce problème mais voilà
allons allons de l'avant quoi sur un
sujet qui fait consensus me semble-t-il
on va finir cette émission avec un coup
d'air rapide à l'ordre du jour à venir à
l'Assemblée au Sénat les points chauds
de l'agenda parlementaire
[Musique]
et on commence avec le Sénat mardi début
de l'examen de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage un texte en partie durci en
commission cette semaine le même jour le
ministre des comptes publics est
auditionné sur le projet de financement
de la sécurité sociale et mercredi soir
il est nécessaire il y a un débat
organisé en séance sur la guerre en
Ukraine et à l'Assemblée nationale de
grands temps fort alors du jour lundi la
discussion des deux motions de censure
déposées respectivement par la nupes et
par le rassemblement national et puis
mardi vote solennelle sur le projet de
loi qui fixe un cadre pour les finances
publiques sur 5 ans qui avait été rejeté
par les parlementaires en première
lecture un dernier mot pour conclure
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du débat sur
l'Ukraine et il y a toujours une
inanimité politique pour pour défendre
l'ukra et les soutenir vous le voyez je
pense que en tout cas au Sénat il y a
effectivement une unanimité pour
soutenir le peuple le peuple craignant
qui est en grande souffrance et pour
condamner le
monsieur Poutine et tous ceux qui l'ont
qui l'entourent il faut vraiment
au-delà de ces soutiens au peuple
Ukrainiens au-delà des condamnations à
l'égard de la Russie je pense qu'il faut
vraiment se concentrer les chemins de la
paix doigt avec mais on les a on a les
moyens je pense je pense qu'il peut y
avoir les moyens et c'est terrible parce
que les Ukrainiens sont en grande
souffrance l'hiver arrive etc il va y
avoir des vraiment de gros problèmes je
pense que le chemin existe mais il faut
que tout le monde accepte de le prendre
et on voit bien que c'est pas aussi
livré plus d'armes parce que
il y a sur les livraisons d'armes aussi
vous avez les sanctions également il y a
pas une feuille de papier cigarette
entre votre position et celle de
l'exécutif
mercredi soir vous allez tenir un
discours à ce moment-là vous allez
pouvoir aussi soutenir l'exécutif dans
votre c'est pas moi qui vais le tenir
mais oui oui bien sûr mais je crois que
Pierre Laurent qui est intervenu qui est
sénateur de mon groupe sénateur de Paris
a toujours tenu cette ligne si je peux
dire la livraison d'armes que vous
soutenez oui
on peut pas rester au milieu du pied sur
ce sur ce sujet quand même bon alors
voilà ce sont ce sont des armes bien
évidemment mais il y a un moment donné
il faut aussi savoir accompagner les
peuples en souffrance et voilà c'est la
fin de cette émission sur ces mots on va
se séparer merci et Ian assis d'avoir
été notre invité merci à tous de vous
avoir suivi et rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour ne rien rater des
incontournables du Parlement ciao ciao
[Musique]